While in Australia,
I paid a visit and my respects
to the National Center of Indigenous Excellence,
where I was honored with the traditional
Welcome to Country ceremony,
performed by Uncle Graham King, a Ngiyampaa Elder.
That's a song that comes
straight from this ground here.
No one represents the new face of Indigenous Australia
quite like Adam Briggs, a rapper,
comedy writer, activist
and proud member of the Yorta Yorta Nation.
On my arms I got my tribe, Yorta Yorta.
You're a Yorta Yorta man?
Yeah, and then on my hands is always was, always will be,
which is like a, it's a protest kinda thing.
It's like always was, always will be Aboriginal land.
Right.
I just got drawn on by my friends,
and they just happen to be great artists.
Right, so all these tattoos happened when you were asleep?
Yeah.
For the most part.
You woke up, you got lucky.
Yeah, I coulda had a bunch of dicks.
What is it you're trying to accomplish now?
It's about changing the perceptions
of what an indigenous artist can be.
Right, I think you're the future
of this country, I really do.
Thanks.
And of course my opinion carries no weight here.
Briggs, good on ya!
Good on ya?
That's not what they say, no?
It's like patronizing.
Oh, so I just should have to (bleep) off?
Yeah, a little bit.
Hey Briggs.
Hey.
Off!
Off, man!
Well, I'm the ultimate cultural ambassador.